honduras le pone fin a la crisis
legislativa desde el 23 de enero el
congreso tenía dos juntas directivas
debido a un conflicto en el gobernante
partido libertad y refundación
el ex presidente manuel zelaya
coordinador general de este partido y
los 17 diputados disidentes encabezados
por jorge cálix quien presidía una de
las dos juntas directivas firmaron en la
casa presidencial un acuerdo este
servidor de ustedes ha decidido dar un
paso al costado
no pensando en mi carrera política
simplemente pensando en lo que
más le conviene al pueblo hondureño en
este momento la primera mujer en llegar
a la presidencia de honduras xiomara
castró no participó en la firma del
compromiso que fue anunciado por su
esposo hoy lo que se está haciendo es
precisamente es logrando
legitimidad y logrando legalidad en
cuanto a la voluntad popular expresada
en las urnas
si el partido que ganó las elecciones
que tiene 50 diputados no está unido
respondiendo a la voluntad popular con
su presidenta constitucional de la
república entonces el pueblo no los
acompaña así las cosas el presidente del
congreso es luis redondo el partido
gobernante es el que tiene mayor
representación en el congreso de 128
escaños pero con 50 legisladores no
disfruta de una mayoría de hecho los
derechistas partido nacional y liberal
representan más de la mitad del congreso
con 44 y 22 escaños respectivamente lo
que le representa retos de
gobernabilidad a la mandataria que se
recupera de kobe 19